thank you it is breaking news coming out
of vienna tonight where there are
reports of
several people people being injured
after shots were fired
in the inner city area let's talk to our
europe correspondent
adam parsons what more do we know adam
yeah good evening uh the news coming out
of vienna
is as ever at these situations sometimes
a little confused but what we do know
for a fact
is that the police have confirmed that
there has been at least
one potentially the several shooting
incidents in the austrian capital now
one of these
was either at the main central synagogue
or in the offices
adjoining it that the the head of the
the jewish community in vienna has been
on twitter and saying that it's still
not clear
whether or not the attack was on the the
officers or on the synagogue
itself there are remote reports of other
attacks going on
at the same time and suggestions
of casualties in the city now the moment
those are
unconfirmed uh reports the
austrian police the vienna police have
asked people to stay away from the area
they have specifically asked people not
to post
any video on social media because of i
think
fears that the shooters who are still
operating and they are still looking for
suspects
would be able to look at that video and
work out
uh police positions now clearly a time
of heightened tension right now
in vienna but across much of western
europe uh there is
growing attention about terrorist
attacks here in france i'm in paris
at the moment we've seen a succession of
what president macron has referred to as
islamist
terror attacks one in the northwest
suburbs
of this city seeing amanda head in and
of course a few days ago
three people killed in the notre dame
basilica
uh in nice and yet now attention
focusing
to the austrian capital a video has
emerged i've seen
uh video so far uncorroborated but
certainly one showing a man walking down
the street with what appears to be a
pretty long barrel
weapon another bit of video showing
people
tending to a victim in what appears to
be a restaurant
in vienna so we will be watching the
reactions as they come out from vienna
and of course
specifically comment as it comes from
the vienna police